c'est l'image qui nous vient en tête
quand on parle de tests pcr un
écouvillon et un chatouillement dalle
mais qui n'a rien de particulièrement
agréable
mais pour ces scientifiques de pêches et
océans canada
la procédure de test pcr commence plutôt
ici
avec une visite à la rivière leno
pour prélever un petit échantillon d'eau
rien à voir donc avec la pandémie on ici
aujourd'hui pour la détection de moins
de 12 son père il donc un espèce
particulière la semis des autres a enflé
donc le but est d' effet de voir ce que
l'espace et trésor donc évaluer sa
distribution identifie de l'habitat
critique des espèces la 6è cette sorte
de moule dans la vie ainsi exactement
c'est bel et bien ce donc ont lieu
détecter visuellement la moule on est
capable de détecter faune adn que la
mode de la loge dans l'environnement
côté de la rivière
on est fait aujourd'hui dans les
laboratoires de biologie moléculaire au
centre des pêches du golfe et c'est dans
ce laboratoire que les échantillons
d'eau filtre y sont traités lorsque
l'office il ya aussi d'autres choses qui
restent captés sur le site donc nous on
vient faire leur extraction la vienne
pour farcir qu'on atteint de l'adn
purifier pour france est capable d'être
citée par après
[Musique]
donc j'en ai rendu à l'étape fameux thé
spécial exactement ces instruments ici
vont nous permettre de déterminer si
l'adn de l'espèce en question qu'on
cible est pas raison ou non donc il va
voir un amplificateur
spécifique de la diane de l'espèce qu'on
cherche qui vaut ce talent
de la mundos en péril qui nous intéresse
donc les teintes spéciales vient d'être
complété on est capable de voir ici par
la présence d'une courbe d'amplification
qu'on a bel et bien détecté l'adn de
l'asthme et d'autres en fléau c'est
qu'ils nous indiquent que la môle et
fort probablement présente dans la
rivière en mieux connaissant la science
la distribution de l'espèce et
potentiellement l'habitat crie t on est
capable de prendre des mesures pour
protéger
les tests pcr sont aussi utilisés pour
détecter des pathogènes chez certains
poissons et crustacés ou encore pour
évaluer la présence d'une espèce
envahissante comme le cap-vert le test c
est juste une manière d'aller détecter
si l'adn ou là à rennes d'un organisme
quelqu'un est là ou non
et comme tous les tests pcr se
ressemblent son équipe a accepté de
contribuer au dépistage lakovic 19 quand
la demande a atteint des sommets tandis
que le travail route et n'était plus des
pathogènes qui causent pas de risques
aux humains on a dû prendre des mesures
préventives de ce bord là mais le gros
du travail on était hautement qualifiés
pour le phare
en contrepartie l'évolution rapide de la
science pendant la pandémie leur a aussi
servi par exemple la détection de la
coved apportèrent des échantillons d'eau
donc de travail pour optimiser ses
thèmes et au delà nous servent aussi
dans notre travail pour aller détecter
nos espèces envahissantes
ça a été un point positif de parler vie
pour vous c'est ça à lui seul 1 des
exactement année 1 17 à l'avant
[Musique]